I think it would be more of a time
machine but I don't imagine anything
welcome when I like two years or
something really but it would take two
years give the mptp a goal there we have
to go on forever yes solid i was gonna
say a week but yeah sure I'll go back to
right I fold it already it should be
pointed out no I would you know I would
do something else what that's not a good
answer it obviously gets harder less I
think less even from a Writers Guild
standpoint but from a again the other
people affected it's it's it sucks the
longer you go because you again you're
not punishing them directly but it is
punishing the people who are it's not
gonna go i can't go that long I mean
America needs its desperate housewives
it needs its Grey's Anatomy I think also
there's a certain degree though once you
sort of settle into the strike you just
sort of settle in and you're like I'm
just gonna ride it to the end like I'm i
can't imagine that we I can't him I
can't imagine them right no I become a
financial issue and winery monster I
mean Henry it's hard for us but you know
the corporations are also losing tens of
millions of dollars arguably I think for
the kind of shows that we work on which
has staffs I don't think you'll be
almost impossible for us to like we
couldn't fall we can't feel like we're
not only even if we wanted to like the
staffs would have to everyone would have
to vote are you saying I'll tell these
are difficult yeah you have to get a
foldable television you have to get it
went to twin technologies gone to the
point where you can fold the television
and I'll do it for free wait are you
asking 10 yo what yo oldest a vision
that's right I'll be a television folder
that's how excited I that technology can
you imagine foldable televisions you put
in any pocket oh my gosh imagine that me
the pocket bear those already and you
don't need to fold them Oh Oh what's up
bud what's up robot right now i am a
tango good wow did use an electric
shaver
ha gay love tryst between Peterborough
and Jeff Zucker they settle it in bed
yep I don't know how it ends good god no
I hope not with a lot of concessions but
I'm a month ago be there's a reasonable
compromise in it in in the negotiations
that will be reached oh yeah I hope so
too and I right maybe I must be good I
think it will actually happen but I hope
listen or like America can't stand the
fact that the Oscars are gonna be
cancelled and like there's a huge push
on Congress yet I mean who knows what's
right America in the world can't stand
that and ugly betty is off the air and
like suddenly Congress gets involved
yeah I think it might have to do
something I mean might have to come to
Congress getting involved it's in crazy
that they got involved in the like
baseball steroid scandal so yeah tensley
yeah or you know maybe Google's starts
hiring writers and creates google TV on
the internet and the network's feel the
pressure and we all go back that seems
like that would take a really long time
we're seven weeks or seven weeks it
would yeah I think I think it would be
nice that they just even came back to
Port able to talk we should predict we
should give dates ok let's look it's
still my uncle and the last 165 first
closest lives gives you a year to pull
the types of money pull yeah what's in
this case so what do you say when's it
gonna get oh no I'm gonna say which will
say April uh 13 that's a long time from
now can ya say earlier release great i'm
gonna say january 10 early estate
january tone I like that latest / most
probable day July thirty-first July
thirty-first yeah because the studio's
go out everything and the movie stop
everything July thirty-first sag I mean
sag that's right that's at the movies I
think that's my favorite part is
everyone hatching these conspiracies as
to how everything's gonna go down yeah
like well these people do this then
that's gonna happen and it's all house
of cards yeah really the house of cards
has long since been just a pile of 52
pickup and nothing
I arrived on my hovercar it's the future
right no I even spending I've been
spending money on car it's only a few
days it's the best way to not alienate
you when you come back hey it's only
like six days in the trip investments I
think I make a long line for pencil
sharpening and then cuz i will be up
again fresh paper I think it'll be a
relief I think it'll be a somber relief
when we go back yeah people will be
people will be excited to be back at
work but they will still be weirded out
because we missed so much work and
imagine like the game of ketchup that
we're gonna I mean it'll sort of be like
I'll be going back to like the show that
I work on I started when the show was
starting out and when it first started
don't roll your eyes rather know you're
scared at the show I don't know whatever
I get it let's go I do that it's great
yes do you have a solid or no no not
that it's just that it was sort of a
creative process where was always that
good news like we didn't know we were
doing for so long and I feel like that's
kind of what it'll be like what hope
yeah it'll be X so fresh and new that
it'll be I think it's gonna be weird
it's a little bit like walking into a
ghost town like some people will be
taller yes a people's voices will have
changed no but the point is it's gonna
be writ something where to do that ask
me where to do our jobs again and it's
weird for those of us who are in shows
that are up back on it'll be weird
because the show's been on so like who
knows what the dynamics are like what
could go wrong cut 2 day 3 i'm murdered
there's a stapler in my eye that's how
i'm going down guys yeah me know i think
i think it's gonna be strange i think
it's gonna be I think people will be
happy to be back at work and relieved
but I don't you know I think it will
take a little time for things to get
back to normal and I don't know yeah I'm
a little yeah I mean obviously I can't
wait yeah of course whoever was excited
for desk I did / nervous yeah I'm really
not nervous as much as I'm just so
excited what did what if you've lost it
what if over all this time you've just
totally lost it my ability to be funny
your ability to write I'm serious like
you go back you've been chomping you're
a chopper but then you go there and boom
nothing
Wow what I'm talking to you not to you
thank you I'm glad you confidently yeah
I'm not that worried about it yeah I'm
not worried about it either so I'm
really funny